where you're really going to get hit is
if you switch your context to something
that's different
and if there's unresolved obligation so
really the worst possible thing you
could do would be to look at like an
email inbox
right because here's 20 emails
i can't answer most of these right now
they're completely different like the
context of these emails like okay
there's a grant funding issue or
something like this is very different
than the coding i'm doing
and i'm leaving it unresolved so it's
like someone needs something from me and
i'm gonna try to pull my attention back
the second worst would be something
that's emotionally arousing so if you're
like let me just glance over at twitter
i'm sure it's nice and calm and peaceful
over there right that could be
devastating because you're going to
expose yourself to something that's
emotionally arousing that's going to
completely mess up the cognitive plateau
there and then when you come back to
okay let me try to code again
it's really difficult